ÇDu bist ja immer verŠrgert
Ÿber jedes Buch.È
ÇOh Gott, das klingt, als wŠre ich
ein ÜGrumpy Old ManÝ.È
ÇJa.È
ÇOkay, schaltet nŠchste
Woche wieder ein,
wenn Nicola Steiner und ich
es nochmal miteinander versuchen.È
ÇPhilipp, wir lesen so wahnsinnig viel,
da ist doch irgendwie auch die Frage,
warum lesen wir?
Warum liest denn du?È
ÇIch brauche das Geld.È
ÇSo viel bezahlen wir doch gar nicht.È
ÇIch habe von verschiedenen Zuschauerinnen
und Zuschauern Zuschriften bekommen:
ÇDieser glŸckliche Mensch,
der das geschrieben hat,
scheint noch nie ein schlechtes
Buch gelesen zu haben.È
ÇIm Gegensatz zu dir.
Du liest ja fast ausschliesslich
schlechte BŸcher.È
ÇIch werde gezwungen,
nicht zuletzt
von Nicola Steiner hier,
BŸcher zu lesen,
die ich sonst nicht lesen wŸrde.
Manchmal passiert es,
dass ich dann verzaubert
werde, aber manchmal
passiert es auch,
dass ich denke Nein,
dieses Buch hŠtte gar nicht
geschrieben werden sollen.È
ÇEine Dame schreibt:
ÇIch finde das deswegen
so interessant,
weil es zwei verschiedene
Aspekte beinhaltet.
Einmal Loslšsung von der Welt,
und dann Identifikation mit
anderen Schicksalen und Charakteren.
FŸr mich ist das kein Widerspruch.
Ich finde, gerade in diesem
Vorgang der Auseinandersetzung
verbindet man sich immer
mit der eigenen Welt.È
ÇAlso suchst du immer ein StŸck
Erkenntnis beim Lesen fŸr dich.È
ÇJa, du auch?È
ÇBei mir ist es nicht
so drastisch klar wie bei dir.
Es gibt die Erkenntnis, es gibt
aber auch die Kenntnis,
dass man das kennenlernt.
Und dann gibt es einfach die Zerstreuung.
Wann hattest du denn
das letzte Mal so ein Buch,
wo du Angst hattest davor,
dass es zu Ende geht?È
ÇDas war gerade letzte Woche der Fall.
Das Buch trŠgt den Titel
ÜKritik des MoralismusÝ und ich habe...È
ÇDas war aber ein Sachbuch.È
ÇJa, und ich hab das
so ausgepackt und sagte:
ÜHerrlich, 400 Seiten
Kritik des MoralismusÝ...È
ÇOh Gott, ist nicht wahr?È
Ç...ich freue mich schon.
Ich wusste, das wird
ganz anregend werden.
Und ich kann mit Nicola
darŸber diskutieren,
was in dem Buch steht.È
ÇEs ist interessant, aber du kannst
es mir auch einfach erzŠhlen.
Dann haben wir beide was davon.È
ÇJa, Siehst du?È
ÇIch hatte das das letzte Mal bei
Ann Petry, ÜDie Stra§eÝ.
Das hat mich so
gefangen genommen.
Ich wŸrde das sofort
ein zweites Mal lesen,
einfach vor lauter Freude an der Art,
wie das geschrieben ist.
Das fand ich hervorragend.
Und was habt ihr denn?
Welche BŸcher...?
Welche... Ich weiss
immer gar nicht... 1917.È
ÇGenau. Also machen wir es nochmal.
Was sind eure BŸcher,
eure LiebesbŸcher?È
ÇSo.È